مشاهدينا مجددا الى تعهد وزير الدفاع
الروسي بزياده امدادات الذخيره خلال زياره
قوه بلاده
باوكرانيا وهو تصريح ياتي بعد اتهامات من
ميليشيا بعدم توفير ذخيره كافيه للقوات
على خط المواجهه
هذا ياتي بعد ايام من نسب صحيفه نيورتنز
الامريكيه الى معلومات استخباراتيه ان
روسيا ستشتري ذخائر وملايين قذائف
المدفعيه والصواريخ من كوريا الشماليه
ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤول امريكي قوله ان
المشتريات تشير الى ان الجيش الروسي لا
يزال يعاني نقصا حادا في الامدادات
باوكرانيا لاسباب منها قيود الصادرات
والعقوبات يقول مسؤولون غربيون ان
العقوبات الغربيه تحد من قدره روسيا على
استبدال المركبات والاسلحه التي دمرت في
اوكرانيا وفي وقت سابق من الشعر الحالي
كشفت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان جنود
الاحتياط الروس ربما يستخدمون مجارف في
القتال اليدوي في اوكرانيا بسبب نقص
الذخيره ويقول محللون عسكريون انه على
الرغم من وجود نقص في الذخيره بالفعل الا
ان الصوره اكثر تعقيدا حيث لا تزال القوات
الروسيه تستخدم ضعف كميه الذخيره التي
يستخدمها الجانب الاوكراني
الحديث عن الذخائر وحاجه القوات على
الجبهات تقابل وتعذيرات مماثله من كياد من
نقص ذخيره المدفعيه والصواريخ قبل هجوم
الربيع المضاد الاوكراني ضد روسيا ولكن
الدعم قادم فقبل ساعات نقلت رويترز عن
ثلاثه مسؤولين امريكيين القول ان الولايات
المتحده ستعلن خلال الايام القادمه عن
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
بقيمه مليارين و600 مليون دولار من
المتوقع ان يكون على قائمه الاعداد
الامريكي سته انواع من الذخائر تتضمن
ذخائر الدبابات بالاضافه الى رادارات
للمراقبه الجويه وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات
وشاحنات لنقل الوقود ومن المقرر ايضا
ادراج ذخائر جويه دقيقه ومعدات جسور قد
تستخدمها اوكرانيا للهجوم على مواقع روسيه
وستشمل الحزمه الامريكيه المركبات انقاذ
لمساعده المعدات الثقيله المعطله مثل
الدبابات وقذائف اضافيه لمنظومه
التي قدمتها الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
وسبت ايضا طلبه اوكرانيا من بولندا 100
مدرعه متعدده المهام من طراز رسومات
تصنعها بترخيص من فنلندا بتمويل من
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنى من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد الياس اذن نحن
نتحدث عن شحل الذخيره من الطرفين
الاوكرانيه والروسي لكن الى اي مدى برايك
هذا الواقع
سيجعل استتيكو الميدان محتوما في المستقبل
القريب
حسن ان ياتي من وزير الدفاع ان هناك نقص
هذا امر مهم جدا يعني ياتي من اعلى سلطه
عسكريه في روسيا يعني هذه الحرب التي
تخوضها روسيا اليوم هي الحرب التقليديه
حسب العقيده القتاليه لروسيه عبر التاريخ
الروسي ولكن في المرحله الاولى لم يحسب
لهكذا نوع من الحرب حرب ثابته حرب استنزاف
استهلك فيها في احد الايام حسن
اقتربت روسيه من استعمال 60 الف قذيفه
مدفعيه يوميا هي لم تحسب لهذا الحساب
والنقص هو في الجهتين وفي كل العتاد وهذا
الامر ياخذنا الى ما يسمى بالستيل ميت كما
قلت يعني مرحله الاستنزاف الجمود من هنا
التحضير لمرحله الحركيه من خلال المساعدات
التي تحدثت عنها قبل قليل
لكن الغريب ان شح الذخيره ليس للمره
الاولى التي يتم الحديث عنها لكن على
الرغم من ذلك القوات الروسيه حققت تقدما
يعني مهما كان حجم هذا التقدم لكنها عمليا
على الارض تفوقت على القوات الاوكرانيه
التي تصلها
معدات ودبابات وغير ذلك
الدبابات لم تصل حسن الى درجه متقدمه ولم
تنظم ضمن المنظومه اليوم عندما نلاحظ ما
يزيد او موازين القوى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا الميازين هي لصالح روسيه بالطبع
العديد العدد الذخيره وحتى الان قبل البدء
بكوريا الشماليه تعتمد روسيه على انتاجها
الخاص على سلاحها اما اوكرانيا فهي محكومه
بالمساعدات الغربيه وكل عمليه عسكريه كي
تنجح هي مرتبطه بمباشره بنوعيه السلاح
التي تاتي من الغرب بالطبع يعني يجب ان
ننظر ايضا حسن الى الخسائر في اي تقدم
يعني تسعه اشهر او تقارب على عشره اشهر
مدينه مخموت لا تزال صامده وهناك صراع بين
بريكوجين ممول شركه فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
عن نفس الموضوع الا وهو النقص في العديد
والذخائر هذا الامر النقص في العديد
والذخائر لكن من الجهه او بالاحرى عند
الجهه الروسيه هل يمكن ان يكون حافزا
للقوات الاوكرانيه للتسريع بهجوم الربيع
المضاد هذا اذا
وصلتها الاسلحه اللازمه لذلك
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حناء الخبيره
العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من بيروت